monsieur et pourquoi pas une facture
d'imposition dès lundi des buralistes de
dix départements offriront la
possibilité à leurs clients de régler
imposé facture administrative à l'aide
de leurs bornes française des jeux bien
sûr nous étions plusieurs sur les rangs
dont la poste mais nous avons donc
réussi à l'obtenir dû aussi à notre
maillage et à notre amplitude horaire
avis d'imposition factures de cantine ou
de crèches amendes de stationnement il
suffira de scanner son document est de
régler le tout aux buralistes avec un
maximum de 300 euros en espèces une
démarche supervisé par la direction
générale des finances publiques
c'est le tabac qui ont qui ont signé le
contrat avec des équipes et qui ont fait
la formation parce que on vous lance pas
en dise et d'argent pour l'état sans
avoir eu une formation avant les
buralistes y voient un moyen de
continuer de faire rentrer du flux
malgré la hausse du prix du tabac mais
côté clients on est dubitatif façon moi
je prépare internet simple éviter c'est
plus simple sauf que c'est pas là c'est
pas très bon de promener toutes ces
informations voilà ça reste dans un
cadre limité
chacun sait chacun son rôle d'avoir
tabac l éteindre les jeux après si on
commence à leur donner plus de travail
si le test est d'abord effectué dans
quatre bureaux de tabac du département
au 4 mars sauront 106 pura liste des
yvelines dans 60 communes qui
proposeront ce service avant son
extension à toute la france en juillet
la fédération des buralistes estiment
atteindre les 2 millions d'encaissement
par an